estas frágiles embarcaciones con cientos
de haitianos a bordo simbolizan la
crisis migratoria en américa en la isla
de haití la violencia entre bandas el
hambre y la crisis política expulsan a
la población a un ritmo acelerado con la
inseguridad que matan a uno matando mack
no no tenemos seguridad en verdad nadie
puede salir todo el mundo tiene que
transferir su casa pasando hambre entre
la casa porque no se puede salir si pisa
un pie afuera te mata lo malo lo que
tienen seguridad ya son los
secuestradores esos son los que tienen
seguridad ya que a que arma que andan
con sus almas así matando en su camino
hacia eeuu las corrientes y los vientos
a veces los llevan hasta islas cercanas
como cuba o república dominicana tan
sólo en los últimos seis meses la armada
dominicana interceptó cerca de 1800
haitianos muchos de ellos denuncian
haber sido víctimas de malos tratos por
parte de las autoridades aquí en la
república dominicana hemos visto
este año se ha incrementado las
deportaciones masivas incluso con brote
de violencia de violación de derechos
humanos por parte de las autoridades
migratorias o sea estamos frente
prácticamente a una conjura a nivel
internacional para afectar cada día más
a la población haitiana a los haitianos
que huyen de su país se suman cientos de
miles de migrantes de otras naciones
centroamericanas en busca de asilo en
eeuu una situación crítica que estará en
el centro de los debates de la próxima
cumbre de las américas que se realizará
entre el 6 y el 10 de junio en los
ángeles de eeuu una cita en la que el
gobierno de iovine espera encontrar un
acuerdo migratorio beneficioso para toda
la región